from the horseface director who starts
shooting before finishing scripts based
on a children's cartoon designed to sell
toys comes a movie designed to sell toys
toys you can't even tell apart except
for the black blood this looks like a
cool place together they will unite with
this stuttering teenager no no no to
defeat a bad guy who doesn't appear
until almost two hours into the movie
but in the meantime there's gratuitous
poorni shots of Megan Fox weird racism
and robot fights that are up around
random hug girls Michael Bay was trying
to pork this summer you will say what
until they give the bad guy the thing he
wants they're friggin dead it killed him
seriously it's stupid starving Burger
King at a sonic eBay Cadillac GMC the
stroke
pepto bismal xbox Kirby's Pontiac
Mountain Dew Chevrolet Chevrolet and
introducing Chevrolet battleship I mean
transformers come on they both look the
same
oh man the Ninja Turtles are [ __ ]
based on the tragedy that spawned
thousands of heartbreaking true stories
comes this fake one
jack is an unrealistically sexy peasant
and Rose is a first-class suicidal pair
of boobs